you let me compliment you are in amazing
shape i have to say uh uh
you you i i'm not gonna ask you your age
but you were in incredible shape 76. 76
years old
what are you doing
what is it you're doing to stay so
well there's this thing called the law
of nature there are certain laws you
know
eat properly
rest properly
exercise properly get plenty of sleep
these are all rules and i i'm a
law-abiding guy so uh i get up in the
morning and uh i
put on my workout clothes i go i used to
be a runner is it a star trek uniform is
it an old star
as a matter of fact it is a star trek
t-shirt
however this t-shirt that i'm wearing
right now is a space x t-shirt yeah
it is a fanta you know this is really
exciting because we had nasa you know
government doing uh space exploration
which uh the federation was too
but now we're going into the
phase where private enterprise is going
and elon musk which sounds like an
alien's name but uh he is a real
visionary i mean he is now taking over
where the shuttle program was he's
already created the uh all-electric
sports car tesla and i'm gonna get one
of those i think it's an exciting i
think you're getting one for free now
nice move george
but it's uh before we go what's your
trick you do sit-ups sit-ups push-ups i
do sit-ups i do push-ups how many
push-ups do you do a day 100 every
morning 100 every morning that's very
good
what's your technique because i do
push-ups and i'm just well you know i've
got bad feet uh that's why i can't run
anymore so when i do my push-ups i
have to have my feet uh
my body has to be at an angle which
makes it even more difficult uh doing uh
push-ups and so i gotta uh what i do is
i ha i hook my uh ankles on uh can you
show us right now on this oh you want to
see george i'm gonna pull this out
oh right here yeah yeah yeah i'll do
this let's do this
it was right here
that's my pillow in case i need to nap
yeah
i've seen you do it
all right let's take a look here i'll
take your coat very nice all right now i
hook my
76 year old george takei
formerly of the uss enterprise
you don't have to do this if you don't
want it at home my sofa is actually uh
is it low softer no okay
if you want to not want to do this i can
do it oh there he goes wait a minute
all right
are you gonna count wow look at that
yeah go here we go one one two
[Applause]
thank you very much